I did one of those DNA tests I was I
came back 55 percent uh British and like
30 Irish and then the rest was little
bits and pieces here and there right so
I'm not meant to live in other countries
really am I I meant to just live in
Iceland or something you need
clouds I just need clouds and little
basement pubs don't I do exist you're
evolutionarily Advanced for Northern
climates and and yet you lived in
Australia which is really bad for your
skin yeah yeah that's the worst so
evolutionary wise I should be good at
skiing
well you're good at making vitamin D in
Northern snowy cloudy climates
that's good
um another thing to brag about